et pour en parler avec nous philippe
crevel économiste directeur du cercle de
l'epagne et directeur associé de lorello
échos data bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors boris
johnson a affirmé que cet accord est bon
pour l'ensemble de l'europe et qu'il
permettra la création de nombreux
emplois qu'en pensez vous la négociation
a été longue difficile on a eu le droit
à un jeu de poker menteur
jusqu'au dernier moment et dans une
négociation qui réussit a forcément des
concessions faites par les uns et par
les autres
on va dire que dans le contexte actuel
c'est le moins mauvais des accords qui
permet d'éviter le pire
si le 31 décembre il n'y avait pas eu
d'accord on aurait été dans une
situation très compliquée au niveau des
échanges entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne et cela aurait concerné
également les pêcheurs qui aurait
n'aurait plus le droit de pêcher en zone
britannique dans la limite des eaux
territoriales britanniques donc on est
dans une situation complexe qu'on a
aujourd'hui
avec cet accord justement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez cet accord sur la pêche
alors il prévoit que les pêcheurs
européens et toujours accès aux eaux
britanniques mais moyennant 25 % de
capture en moins avec une clause de
revoyure à l'été elle devait 2026 mais
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant selon vous
pour eux évidemment si on regarde moins
25%
c'est quelque chose qui est difficile
donc à gérer pour une activité qui est
très fragile
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu d'accord du
fait du breakbeat s'était pas moins 25%
c'était moins 100% a donc ils vont
évidemment regarder l'ensemble du
dossier
c'est un problème pour donc le secteur
de la pêche
la commission européenne s'est engagée à
venir en aide donc à ce secteur en
difficulté
en revanche les britanniques auraient pu
l'en cadre de la nouvelle association
dire on leur laisse aucun pêcheur passé
c'est d'ailleurs s'était même mis en
avant boris johnson pour négocier la
possibilité d'avoir
un set en chine au niveau des droits
douaniers sur l'ensemble des
marchandises
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu à brax faire sur
le sujet étonnez vous êtes mal taillée
pour les pêcheurs européens mais sera
beaucoup plus grave
donc pour vous ces concessions sont
acceptables pour pouvoir parvenir donc à
cet accord je pense que ça fait pas si
on n'avait pas eu d'accord on n'y aurait
pas de possibilité d'aller sur les zones
de pêche britannique donc on peut
considérer les britanniques ont fait une
concession
par ailleurs l'idée était essayé d'avoir
cette zone douanière unique entre le
royaume uni et union européenne
on l'obtient sur les marchandises on ne
l'obtient pas pour les services il faut
le souligner et d'autre part pour ce qui
est des normes
on a également gagné en disant que le
royaume uni deux races soumettre un
minimum de normes en particulier comme
vous l'avez dit au niveau
environnemental ou au niveau du droit
social
alors on parle d'un accord signé sur un
modèle de libre échange à la canadienne
selon le premier ministre britannique
qu'est-ce que cela signifie l'idée que
des sons boris johnson depuis le début
c'est d'avoir donc à libre échange sans
en avoir forcément les contraintes
telles qu'on les connaît
au sein de l'union européenne à travers
l'interdiction de toute subvention pour
les entreprises ou par ailleurs des
normes de plus en plus contraignantes
erronées sur un minima de normes pour le
royaume uni
donc ils sortent eux à de libre échange
très simple sans organisation du marché
c'était l'objectif johnson il l'a obtenu
en partie
ça fait partie donc là on voit bien le
talent de négociateur des britanniques
qu'ils ont gagnés sur plusieurs points
ils ont également fait quelques
concessions ça fait partie du jeu de la
négociation est ce qu'on peut imaginer
maintenant que le royaume uni va
davantage se tourner vers les pays outre
atlantique en les etats-unis le canada
le royaume uni quand même très intégré à
l'union européen à l'europe depuis 73
depuis en fait sa participation à la
communauté économique européenne il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses
l'éclatement des chaînes de valeur et le
royaume uni donc participent à chaque
puzzle économique et le premier symbole
c'est airbus et des pièces d'airbus qui
vont royaume uni est là qui ressorte
pour aller sur les chaînes de montage
à hambourg ou et toulouse pareil pour
l'automobile l'automobile britannique
était au fond du trou
car rebondi grâce à des investisseurs
étrangers comme nissan ou comme toyota
évidemment elle participe on va dire à
l'ensemble du marché automobile européen
et on ne pouvait pas homologué ni coupé
complètement donc la production
britannique du reste de l'europe
c'est pour ça qu'il était important
d'avoir accès libre échange et le fait
que le royaume uni aujourd'hui le
exporte à 46% gens semblent son
exploration vers l'europe et donc est
complètement intégré leurs homards
peut-être que les états unis mais pourra
dire que le coeur de son activité reste
au même en europe pour les nombreuses
années le royaume uni qui reste donc
toujours lié à l'europe c'est ce que
vous me dites merci beaucoup à philippe
crevel je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste directeur du cercle de
l'épargné et directeur associé de
lorello échos date